[Music]
and bad reaction news um submitted by
blessed by Jason a bad reaction to a
one-star Amazon review up ended an
entire company Wow up ended me offended
and up ended no I like it pretty much
like the end of their company is it done
and it like a big final end like
completely sure it don't finish I say Z
1 to Z and easy the company yeah wow
this just like dunkey zzzz exited on
that you would understand it with that
oh that's right no done DZ we strike
done D do that [ __ ] you can see
[ __ ] so what are the review say
sighs this product is called garage it
what's that it's like a tiny little
device that you stick on your garage
door opener like the the motor that
actually brings up the garage for you
yes and so you stick that on there and
it is also laser it has like some sort
of laser and then you know technical
reflective sticker on your actual door
and what this product does is it
notifies you via an app whether you left
your garage door open or not we're like
forgetful people that constantly just
forget to close the garage that is me
yeah so I mean would you pay $90 oh no
because I found out that buy my car can
actually do it for me automatically now
really how do you forget the cause of
garage door well the last time you had a
garage like a garage right oh I've been
having it for like two weeks sometimes
ah yeah I should come home in the garage
doors open I'm like what the [ __ ]
someone left with it open any comments I
did a couple times in my brother had to
remind me and then I realized that my
car like once I leave the proximity
it'll do it automatically though Roscoe
that's like a Tesla technology man this
person named Martin bought this product
and they decided like to write a
one-star review because it was a piece
of [ __ ] is what they said kind of sounds
like a piece of [ __ ] you need a mirror
it sounds all high-tech
and then it's like you need a mirror you
need some velcro and some superglue you
know it's not that high tech anymore
so this person left a review on Amazon
where they purchase that product and on
the actual product forum on their
webpage yeah they were like furious I'm
going to show you guys what they wrote
on the Amazon one and this is like the
censored version because the other one
just Pikachu
piece of [ __ ] oh [ __ ] [ __ ] it means I'll
do
hey you freak but it's not you gonna
bleep it up anyway so here we go
this is a one-star it says junk do not
waste your money
iPhone app is a piece of Education it
says Johnson all waste your money
iPhone app is a piece of junk crashes
constantly startup company that
obviously has not performed proper
Quality Assurance test on their products
so that's that was the review but on the
actual site they wrote piece of [ __ ] Oh
Dale then that's when the CEO like the
main guy I created this product they
decided to respond to this angry bending
terrible Zuckerberg like seriously
Martin the abusive language here and in
your negative Amazon review submitted
minutes after experience a technical
difficulty only demonstrates your poll
impulse control I'm happy to provide the
technical support to the customers on my
Saturday night but I'm not going to
tolerate any Tantrums at this time your
only option is return a garage it to
Amazon for refund your unit ID to f zero
zero three six will be the night service
connection so that's a response instead
of helping you like to call them
impulsive pretty much yeah
but the main thing here is that he
didn't even help his customer she said
I'm gonna deny your connection to our
servers you can even use the product
like this it's the worst accident how
old is the Felix well pretty cut up
right yeah so then that's when people
started going crazy on this product
because it there was a Twitter account
that picked up on this and then they put
it out in a talkin how can you leave a
review they didn't even buy the product
he did buy this on people I mean other
people you're probably looking at the
review for the product they saw that
response and Psyche you [ __ ] oh I
thought it was just a bunch of other
people leaving review than what well
then after this went viral then yes a
lot of people went on and they started
putting a lot of one-star review
saying like you know this is like poor
customer service I think that's not how
you treat your customers and things like
that and so it pretty much like ruin
this company because what he said was
basically she's like hey
you're obviously too stupid to use my
product don't use it anymore yeah that's
what happened with the [ __ ] socially
unintelligent [ __ ] nerd gets a hold
of a business and they don't know how to
deal with people yeah well actually
you're just too intelligent to [ __ ]
deal with my products so I'm not going
to give it to you because you're not
smart enough there it is [ __ ] ah yeah
way I don't tolerate bad language no bad
words in my company forum yeah so this
man the company owner his name is Dennis
and then some manners yeah so Dennis
like after all these like ever met a
dope Dennis you're that all Dennis's are
for the weird but what about our ad
Dennis while your school is also kind of
weird basically cool anyways so then
that's when Dennis decided to respond to
all these negative Oh awesome
you've gone teddy yeah every single one
let's do it one minute on I recently I
just have one more all right there what
kind of CEOs in fine with everybody
because it looks like David would you
like to read okay calm down everybody
save your pitchforks and torches for
your elected representative this only
lacks the death threats now the firing
of the customer was never about the
Amazon we just wanted to distance from
the toxic individual ASAP admittedly not
a slickest PR move on my part access
restored note take it oh my god it was
like a robot
yeah taken access restored not taken
very much useful types like you hate
[ __ ] yeah get away from me women but it
sounds like hahaha you know what it is
is just kind of like there are certain
people who are very good at one thing
that they do so it's like for example
it's like a chef right they can make the
most amazing foods but there's a reason
why certain chefs they don't talk to
customers they just create food so
that's kind of what this guy is he's
probably like an amazing inventor this
is what he does but now he's trying to
open up a business and there's a
customer service aspect to it which he
is not accustomed to yeah for him it's
just like I created this don't think
everybody should like it it's like no
not really
that's not how like selling products
where people have to like you as you
land a company to to in order to invest
into it and that's how people view
products and this is my investment of my
money in time you respond that to your
customer base people are going to
[ __ ] hate you
yeah and that's what happened here this
is by someone who fed just hire me to
talk to I do it we should have customer
service and customer disservice that
because of a disservice sound like I'll
make it one yeah the guy kept responding
to like negative target yeah that'd be
funny like if you you know how when you
call they have different options like
option one customer service option two
customer disservice it will just tragedy
yeah listen [ __ ] no [ __ ] returns you
poor sack of [ __ ] I always trying to do
trying to [ __ ] ball my dress for a
[ __ ] date and then you return it back
[ __ ] that not only did that once
okay I'll come no [ __ ] [ __ ] stains
back I don't take [ __ ] stain return and
then customer service is the Filipino
one but customer deserve is American no
I am so sorry too good that sir they
always have like the same lines yeah I
understand your frustration we always
say that - oh yeah don't forget to leave
a review for me here I like the for nine
minutes customer service people because
they won't ever hang up on you abruptly
they'll say help you all y'all can have
a lot of patience and cue other pictures
really you pee like when I dealt with my
ups in that [ __ ] Robert situation dude
met the American person trying to hang
up on me multiple times like they're
like okay so I'm like no no you don't
put me on hold so I could I could they
took kinda different yeah so I just
never let them up so you put me on
[ __ ] hold imma flip the [ __ ] out so
like you stay here you solve this [ __ ]
I'm not sure what back point today or to
give you their name and everything you
can report on to get them fired like
that so it's not smart for them that's
the first thing you ask for it no for
you guys if you call customer service
immediately ask for their names yeah I'm
not trying to get you fired but if you
don't want to do your job and you want
to do that's not there for me
and if you work customer service lie
hello my name is Nancy
okay Nancy I got all these fittings so
Nancy there's no Robert Russell a bond
if you suck up just hang up and they
call back yes I call them Nancy we don't
even have that person working here you
[ __ ] imagine how furious you
would be in that with you I know huh
that's why word of advice ask for the
name immediately and if you work as
customer service give a fake name they
can backtrack because I what that's why
they have all those conversations
recorded now as I called it this time
and dadadada could trace it back
Wow bad advice to Dennis he got
interviewed by Mashable and he was
saying that like in a response to all
this he says that it was an unusually
emotional call and that this was a
lesson that's hard to ignore noted
mm-hmm access granted that's just one of
those things he's an amazing inventor he
should not deal with customer service he
should have left after somebody else
yeah fact that he has somebody who was a
part of the brand responded like that he
can't even differ by a customer service
skills sometime really just my brain I
wish I had a customer service person in
my imagine if you had a customer service
person in your head that dealt with
problems for you in your head some
reason I just imagine like a reception
does it make somebody like walking it
with a cup of coffee and like just
sitting down is like okay how can I help
you today because I don't want to read
an email and think you just [ __ ] [ __ ]
people
I want all customer service deal with
this you say that the email goes okay
I'm sorry I understand your frustration
sorry oh thank you very much and it's
like a nice little Filipino lady or like
an Indian guy yes like it's hard though
sometimes to even you know like I own a
small business and there's like certain
reviews for the people leave and like
for example there's just one lady who is
completely bashed it right for me I'm
like oh I'm sorry you had such a bad
time the knows like next time like I'm
sorry that ever happened but please give
us another chance and next time you know
ice creams on us this person wrote back
to us you can't tell me what to do I
don't have to come back to your place
ever again oh I was like fatty grasses
all I get I don't even know how to
apologize like great apologizing over
this you know cuz I fell genuinely bad
and this person is like you can't tell
me what to do you don't own me
like one of those oh whoa awesome uh she
left accident it just kind of whatever
she said no matter yeah where did you
tell me what to go eat sushi the other
day oh yeah I went to eat sushi the
other day right and Oh Massa and uh no
Tokyo and oh I didn't mention to this
lady was like a British lady and so it's
me Adric and a few other friends and
we're sitting there and she gets like a
California rule rights and a California
rolls or dope they put Ely put
everything on there and she gets like a
piece of the hamachi and how much if you
guys don't know when you slice it up
like depending on what part of the line
that you get is going to be a different
color yeah so she goes she goes excuse
me
[ __ ] what is this it knows how much it
feels this is not hamachi she throws it
on the floor and then she [ __ ] storms
out what's she eating by ourselves
yeah she's eating my revered and I was
like hold already eating before that
notice she didn't touch it at all she
just picked up with their toss it like
this is you know what is this this is
not a matcha nation
this is not some matching campaign how
she paid and then she stormed out and I
feel pain and I was like I like that um
this is a interesting that you're
telling a Japanese chef who doesn't even
speak English
what hamachi is like I'm pretty sure it
is and that place is good yeah you know
I eat that yeah and I was like what the
[ __ ] is this [ __ ] doing that's crazy
mmm hey guys I hope you enjoyed that
episode of just kidding news if you guys
have any fun or exciting stories you
want to share with us go ahead and
cruise down to the description box below
and there's a link where you can submit
for more videos click up here
[Music]